Deep blue,
the IBM computer beat Garry Kasparov,
I'm getting weirdly has resigned is a
whole new team of humans going up against
opening I five is defining vision for AI.
Research has always been to eventually
create an algorithm that can solve any
problem. It's Cs and given the
recent rapid advances in Ai,
we are getting closer.
Reinforcement learning is a subfield of
machine learning in which the goal is to
learn how to act in an environment
to maximize our reward signal.
There have been lots of different
algorithms proposed to help this goal,
many of which involve learning a
way to represent all or part of the
environment,
but learning a general representation
of diverse data was shown to be a hard
problem and the promises of reinforcement
learning in large part were left
unfulfilled.
But in recent years hope emerged when
deep learning proved to be able to learn a
robust representation of whatever
type of data it was given.
The combination of these two approaches
called deep reinforcement learning is
what's behind the latest advances in Ai.
Deep RL is now making its way
into industrial applications
created by companies
both big and small pit dot.
Ai is now using it to outperform
traditional hedge funds by applying it to
algorithmic trading.
The Vu is using it to address the
challenges of managing complex enterprise
supply chains.
Uber has applied it at massive scale to
be able to more efficiently match riders
and drivers together and Oh sorrows
using it to create some of the smartest
factory robots ever made.
Helloworld it Saroj and
join me as I teach it.
This free 10 week
reinforcement learning course.
I've called move 37 I'll take you on a
journey through the basics up to modern
day techniques.
Every week we'll build apps together
that will cover both toy and industry
problems.
You'll be able to measure your progress
along the way by chatting with your
peers,
both online and offline at
school of AI chapters globally,
taking quizzes, coding challenges,
and two graded projects.
I'll have weekly coding live streams
to help answer any questions and my
assistant instructors will be available
to help in our community slack channel.
All Wizards who complete this course,
get an official school of
Ai Certificate signed by me.
This is going to be a wild ride.
So sign up now and join our movement.